républicain la parole est à monsieur
jean claude mignon merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
le 24 novembre dernier un avion russe a
été abattu par deux chasseurs turcs près
de la frontière syrienne
alors qu'il était en mission pour
combattre l'état islamiste deux
militaires russes ont perdu la vie dans
des conditions qui sont tout à fait
dramatique puisque les deux pilotes
avaient réussi à s'éjecter
l'un est sain et sauf et l'autre a été
abattu alors qu'il dansait descendez un
parachute et conditions dans lesquelles
cet avion est abattu son flou est
incertaine la russie conteste le fait
qu'elle a violé qu'elle aurait violé
l'espace aérien turc et conteste
également le fait qu'elle aurait été
prévenu à maintes reprise avant d'être
abattu par les deux chasseurs turcs la
turquie bien évidemment s'est empressé
de saisir et de demander en urgence une
réunion du conseil de l'otan pour comme
pour se protéger d'ailleurs et pour
trouver quelques soutiens au sein de
l'otan le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
véritablement qu'est ce qui est ressorti
de cette réunion de cette organisation
la france a réintégré il ya quelques
temps le commandement intégré de l'otan
pouvez vous nous dire aujourd'hui avec
précision quelle est la position de
l'otan vis-à-vis cette agression et puis
surtout bien évidemment quelle est la
position du gouvernement français de la
france vis-à-vis de cette agression dont
ont été victimes je le dis vient encore
une fois un avion de nos alliés de nos
alliés russes est également vis-à-vis du
fait que des militaires ont perdu la vie
dans les conditions tout à fait
dramatique merci de votre réponse
merci monsieur mignon l'appareil d'état
chargée du commerce extérieur de la
promotion du tourisme et des français de
l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean claude mignon je veux une nouvelle
fois d'abord vous demander de bien
vouloir excuser le milieu affaires
étrangères pour son absence il préside
en ce moment même la coque 21 mai
monsieur le député vous avez rappelé
avec beaucoup de gravité la situation
complexe et tendue qui est là
aujourd'hui c'est vrai les tensions sont
fortes
entre la russie et la turquie depuis la
destruction en plein vol
le 24 novembre dernier d'un chasseur
bombardier russe par la turquie à la
frontière de la syrie une réunion des
ministres affaires étrangères s'est
tenue dans le cadre l'otan hier à
bruxelles et la situation de la turquie
la situation que vous évoquez et les
sollicitations de la turquie ont
évidemment été évoquée
les alliés dans le cadre de l'otan ont
manifesté leur soutien à la turquie et
leur attachement profond à l'intégrité
de son espace aérien
sur la question de l'avion russe a battu
je rappelle les positions de la france
telles qu'elles ont été présentées par
le président de la république dès le
lendemain de ces faits lorsqu'il était
aux états unis à washington précisément
pour construire la coordination dans la
lutte contre des ch
d'abord un appel au calme et le besoin
d'un diagnostic précis un appel aussi à
la désescalade et au dialogue entre
ankara et moscou sur cette affaire et la
france se félicite que dans le cadre de
la réunion qui s'est tenue hier semble
s'esquisser une discussion directe y
compris entre les deux ministres des
affaires étrangères russe et turque et
la france prendra toute sa part pour
contribuer à la désescalade nécessaire
et indispensable pour faire descendre
les tensions et améliorer la situation
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe socialiste républicain